défi
communisme communisants
d'hommes semblables le niveau
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
scopeo l'observatoire politique je suis
l e10 membres de scoopeo et je vous
souhaite la bienvenue sur ce sixième
épisode de notre série l'antre du
politique aujourd'hui nous sommes très
heureux de recevoir monsieur dominique
reynié politologue émérite professeur à
sciences po travaillant sur les grands
enjeux sociétaux économiques et
politiques pour discuter avec lui de la
place des libertés à notre époque mais
avant tout je laisse la parole à 2010
elle co fondatrice de scopeo coûts
qu'elles puissent poser le décor de
cette entrevue
merci elodie bonjour voir celle des
cieux qui nous écoutent et surtout
bonjour à vous monsieur dominique reynié
et les aux majors
bonjour bonjour vous nous fait le
plaisir de nous accorder cette entrevue
pour discuter ensemble de liberté plus
précisément de la place de liberté de
nos jours en effet le thème de cet
entretien portera sur la question d'un
recul ou alors d'une avancée des
libertés dans origine dans un contexte
de crises successives qui sont souvent
susceptibles de les mettre à mal mais
avant de démarrer l'entrevue monsieur le
major et dominique reynié je vous laisse
vous présentez vous et votre enquête
pour fondapol intitulé liberté les
fautes de siècle pour ceux qui nous
écoutent
alors donc liberté c'est une étude
réalisée par la fondapol
accompagné d'autres semi tank hawaii
ainsi parcs américains meurent
république a des manières en citant
brésilien
fundación ovationné rationner sans son
argentin
community of the rock le 6 1 sont donc
européen basé à varsovie et la fondation
conrad adenauer en allemagne donc nous
avons engrangé
à exergue un drame horrifique un think
tank japonais voilà ça fait quand même
c'est très massif on a interrogé plus de
47000 personnes à travers une
cinquantaine de pays j'ai pu le chiffre
exact on pète et donc nous avons posé
des questions sur différents thèmes
transversaux allant de à
30,2 des grandes puissances avec la
russie la chine les etats unis ou plus
particulièrement sur les libertés ou sur
l'europe nous avons adapté les questions
différents pays de l' enquête
voilà c'est bien présenté par pas parler
aux majors il ya 55 pays et
tout a été bien dit
moi je ne suis pas encore émérite on
émérite quand on est un ancien
professeur je suis toujours à l'activité
j'espère que j'ai des mérites
on est on est très heureux d'avoir mené
cette enquête avec les partenaires donné
au majorat cité
puisque le projet on peut quand même
dire ça peut être ça peut être utile le
projet que l'on poursuivants c'est la
troisième enquête la première portait
sur 26 pays ensuite sur 42 là c'est 55
et l'idée c'est d'arriver à convaincre
des partenaires dans le monde entier
pour être capable peu à peu de faire
tous les deux ans peut-être même tous
les ans un état de la démocratie dans le
monde avec le plus de pays possible 55
c'est beaucoup il ya aussi beaucoup de
pays qui ne sont pas parce qu'il faut
avoir des moyens et donc on a besoin de
convaincre des partenaires et si nous
pouvions faire dans le futur une enquête
annuelle suivre sans pays par exemple on
serait très très heureux je dirais
l'objectif serait atteint
juste pour poser le cadre de scopeo nous
on se concentre de manière générale
plutôt sur la france c'est donc le cas
de neuf ans donc on va surtout se
concentrer sur l'aspect français où les
démocraties le système démocratique
de manière générale mais c'est vrai que
l'entrevue est très complexe et il
couvre énormément de zones vente comme
vous l'avez dit donc on laissera ceux
qui nous écoutent retrouver la situation
du reste des pays directement dans
l'étude qu'on mettra en barre d'infos
sur youtube
alors on va commencer avec la première
question donc dès l'introduction de
votre enquête vous verrez c'est le
portrait d'une globalisation bien sûr
fruit du triomphe du régime démocratique
sur le communisme comme absolument
profitable au développement et au
renforcement des riches gym autoritaire
en effet si l'agglo visait globalisation
pardon est un symbole de triomphe elle
n'en est pas l'outil de jours selon vous
comment dans les pays développés
désindustrialisation métropolisation et
autres renforcement des inégalités
sociales la mobilisation se placera
aujourd'hui en allié des régimes
autoritaires en favorisant leur dise
colin fournissant le site de nouveaux
moyens d'influencer le monde et de
déstabiliser les sociétés libérales
partant de ce constat pensez vous que la
survie du modèle démocratique dépend
d'un abandon du principe de
globalisation où est il possible à force
de régulation et de limitation de
refaire de la globalisation un atout au
service de l'idéal démocratique
bon c'est une masse question que vous
posez évidemment il ya toujours une
forme d'orgueil à répondre à une telle
question comme ça en quelques mots mais
enfin ces exercices
là
sion est pleine de vertus
et notamment sa s'est documenté c'est
pas un autre étude les travaux le montre
beaucoup les institutions comme la
banque mondiale et d'autres universités
etc non documentés il ya une tendance
sur les trente dernières années à
l'enrichissement
relatif de pays très pauvres
et donc à une réduction des inégalités
entre les grands systèmes
géopolitique ça peut avoir pour
conséquence d'appauvrir hélas des pans
de la société à l'intérieur et
démocratie ou d'accroître des inégalités
mais il y as phénomène malgré tout deux
d'enrichissement des pays les plus
pauvres même si c'est relative et ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle il faut que ça
se maintiennent tous les humains ont le
droit d'accéder au confort et même à la
prospérité donc c'est faux pas sans
doute imaginer que c'est par remettant
en cause l'enrichissement des pays
pauvres on y trouverait nous quelques
sources de bonheur ou de réconfort par
contre on est sans doute à la fin d'un
premier cycle de globalisation
qui en effet maintenant profite beaucoup
aussi aux régimes autoritaires vous vous
l'avez dit qu'ils sont capables
d'absorber le capitalisme d'en prendre
toute la puissance de renforcer leur
propre état autoritaire sans rien céder
à la liberté politique en gardant tout
pour la puissance de l'état grâce au
capitalisme planétaire ça c'est une
première chose qui pose problème
puisque ce sont quand même des régimes
menaçant et puis ensuite parce qu'il
faut réguler comme vous l'avez dit cette
globalisation peser davantage sur
certaines de ses forces et ses forêts
faire en sorte que des éléments
aujourd'hui problématique par exemple le
réchauffement climatique appelle une
régulation mais aussi les biftecks les
gars femmes qui ont beaucoup de pouvoir
et sans vrai contre partis politiques
doivent être régulés et d'autres sujets
encore la recherche de technologies est
une ressource considérable
il faut la régler pourquoi ne produisent
pas n'importe quoi mais à l'échelle
planétaire on ya beaucoup de sujets je
ferai pas une liste donc jusque-là sang
il ya beaucoup de sujets très stratégie
qui montre que nous avons besoin d'une
régulation et ça c'est sans doute
la sphère d'une concertation entre les
états et sans doute que pour des raisons
de valeur convergente des tic
convergentes les démocraties dans le
monde hot la capacité ou philosophique
morale peut-être police politique aussi
de fédérer un projet qui pèserait
davantage sur la marche du monde en
termes de régulation plutôt que d'avoir
une régulation qui seraient tentés de
façon dispersée par chaque pays qui
aurait son mot à dire
des citations qu'on retrouve dans notre
étude je cite donc sans la liberté de
débattre et de publier il ne reste rien
de modèle démocratique
elle ne conditionnent elle conditionne
la possibilité la légitimité mais aussi
l'efficacité
énormément de journalistes mais aussi
d'intellectuels dénonce aujourd'hui en
affaissement de cette liberté de
débattre et de publier beaucoup pointent
du doigt la comme celle çi et
l'hégémonie de ce qu'on appelle le
politiquement correct vous semblez
partager cette analyse en dénonçant plus
loin je cite le déclin de la liberté au
sein de l'université ainsi quelles
conséquences de ce manque de liberté
pour le modèle démocratique français
là je réponds aussi parce que ça ça ça
renvoie à des préoccupations au sein de
la fondation pour l'innovation politique
mais aussi avec lesquels pour ma part
comme universitaire je me sens en accord
c'est à dire que il y a au sein des
universités du monde académique mais
aussi maintenant sur les réseaux sociaux
et dans les entreprises il y a une
tendance à créer
des systèmes de censure et de pressions
sur
les propos que l'on peut avancer sur ce
qu'il est licite
d'examiner ce qui ne l'est pas sur ce
que l'on peut dire est que je ne peux
plus dire bref c'est le retour d'une
forme de système contraignant voir
répressif par des effets de de pression
encore une fois ça c'est le secret de la
catastrophe c'est à dire que dans le
monde démocratique d'une part a fortiori
aux 5 d'académique et universitaire la
règle d'or c'est la liberté c'est de
pouvoir s'exprimer faire des hypothèses
argumenté parvenir à discuter à
convaincre pas toujours peut-être même
pas souvent mais peu importe la
possibilité d'exprimer un point de vue
d'examiner un objet de recherche et je
complète ma question 2010la votre
réponse à votre question dans le fait
que typiquement
les inégalités entre les individus entre
les groupes
les inégalités entre les genres les
inégalités entre les personnes selon
leur origine sur leurs croyances
toutes les formes d'inégalités toutes
les formes de discriminations sont des
objets légitime de discussions de
réflexions au sein du monde deux en
général dans l'espace public bien sûr
mais aussi au sein de l'université sont
des objets de recherche
nous devons pouvoir examiner ces sujets
là sans verser dans une forme
d'idéologie politique qui à la fin
bien aura raison c'est à dire
mettre détruira la liberté universitaire
mais aussi la possibilité de réfléchir
de façon objective sur ces inégalités
cette discrimination
c'est à dire aussi de les traiter de
répondre c'est au coeur j'ai terminé un
dernier argument là dessus à
l'université cdc en grosse des vieux
avec des jeunes des vieux c'est les
profs en l'évitant et les jeunes ces
étudiants les étudiants qui viennent à
l'université c'est l'épreuve de demain
c'est l'écart de demain c'est des
ministres de glace et puis ce qu'on
voudra de demain s'ils ne sont pas
socialisée à la liberté intellectuelle
en tant que journaliste plus tard
politique je ne sais quoi nous la ferons
pas vivre non plus et donc on commence
dès maintenant à appauvrir la liberté
futur si on ne préserve pas au sein de
l'université la plus grande liberté en
matière de discussions avec des réserves
qui sont élémentaires il n'ya pas
d'incitation à la haine ou à la violence
qui soit acceptable il n'y a pas de
diffamation qui sont acceptables il n'y
a pas de fausses nouvelles ou de
mensonges sur la réalité sont
acceptables à part cela on peut discuter
nous tous ils sont arrivés m
alors dans une optique plus politique
c'est comme si la culture est très très
très décrié sur concernant les champs
politique etc et pourtant malgré la
dangerosité de cette quand celle que le
tueur pour la liberté d'expression ce
sont les camps politiques qui la dénonce
le plus c'est à dire aujourd'hui la
droite et l'extrême droite qui sont
largement en force à l'aube des
élections présidentielles comme on le
voit particulièrement dans les sondages
comment est ce que vous expliquez ce cas
ce paradoxe que les camps les politiques
qui est se plaignent d'être
silence y est soit ceux qui ont le plus
de succès auprès des citoyens
alors dans notre étude et léo s'en
souvient on a des questions je parle
bien de la france on a des questions sur
ce que vous vous sentez bien représentée
par les médias et où parler politique et
au niveau des 55 pays on a une tendance
à ne pas se sentir très bien représentée
par les médias ou par les politiques
c'est un score assez moyen c'est plutôt
pas bon mais alors en france c'est un
record c'est à dire qu'en france ces 20
points au dessus de la moyenne pour dire
qu'on ne se sent pas représenté par les
médias on ne se sent pas représenté par
les politiques il ya un problème
spécifiquement français je fais le lien
il votre question on a les français nous
disent qu'ils n'ont pas interrogé nous
interrogeons il n'a pas tous interrogés
mais l'échantillon france interrogé nous
disent que on n'a pas le sentiment quand
on écoute les journalistes quand on
écoute des politiques qu'ils parlent de
la vie que l'on mène est là c'est aussi
ça une explication si vous voulez parce
qu'à un moment donné quand on offre aux
citoyens la possibilité de faire quelque
chose pas simplement de dire quelque
chose mais de faire par exemple si on
passe du domaine de l'opinion
à l'action de domaine de l'opinion au
vote est bien là et qu'on a envie de
tout le monde n'est pas un échantillon
mais tout le monde à dire
ce qu'ils préfèrent et bien là on
s'aperçoit tout d'un coup que comme vous
l'avez dit eh bien il ya une espèce de
de france de droite qui s'exprime de
populisme de droite qui s'exprime avec
force comme s'il y avait une forme de
retour de ce qui n'a pas été conçu
considéré avec suffisamment de soins et
qui peut donner le sentiment
assez assez assez assez électeurs lassés
citoyens que le monde tel qu'il est
présenté n'est pas celui dans lequel ils
vivent ça ils participent beaucoup quand
on voit les débats extrêmement pointus
ou idéologique qui peuvent être liés à
de nouvelles de nouveaux enjeux de la
discussion au sein du monde
universitaire on en a parlé du moc isme
on a souvent le sentiment dans la
plupart des des parties de notre société
très largement qu'il s'agit de
discussions unique matic
incompréhensible donc c'est une forme
aussi de ces le progrès c'est la
progression c'est la part au sens du
progrès mais c'est la progression de la
maturation d'une crise de la
représentation dans sa généralité je
veux pas vous prendre de la parole doute
dans les eaux
j'ajouterai à cela qu'on a on a remarqué
dans l'étude que la france en compte
dans les toutes les démocraties mais en
particulier en france qu' il y avait
cette crainte de ne pas pouvoir résoudre
les désaccords pacifiquement qu'il y
avait cette crainte d'une augmentation
de la violence la l'impossibilité de de
se mettre d'accord de partager quelque
chose et donc c'est un sentiment qui est
extrêmement présent et on est ça
alimente cette crise de la démo passion
c'est peut-être plus le la résultante je
ne sais pas mais en tout cas c'est
c'est ce qu'on a ce qu'on a montré skis
ce qui est inquiétant c'est que ce n'est
pas que la france qui à cette heure là
c'est beaucoup de pays dans le monde et
donc c'est ce sur quoi nous à la
fondation l'a voulu mettre l'emphase
c'est sur cette crainte qu'ont les
citoyens sur la démocratie joue son
fonctionnement et sur l'avenir de leur
liberté
je vais rebondir ce que vous avez pu
dire en début de semaine il ya le
candidat présidentiel eric zemmour qui
est intervenu chez france inter et qui
en est qui a bien dit au présentateur
qu'il représente est la gauche et que le
peuple ne se sentait pas représentée par
cette radio et du coup il voulait les
privatiser est-ce que la privatisation
est une solution pour pour plus pour un
espace plus libre au niveau de la
liberté d'expression et ensuite
je vais revenir sur la question du passé
ni terre parce qu'on va rentrer dans les
débats présidentiels
certains candidats aux élections ne sont
pas vaccinés et dans certaines émissions
de débat les chaînes de télévision vont
demander un passé militaire comme il est
demandé parce vacciner à pardon excusez
moi comme il est demandé au public
est-ce que là aussi ça rentre ça rend
dans la problématique de la liberté
d'expression et dans tout le champ des
candidats qui nous est proposé pour
cette élection pour cette élection qui
est quand même
déterminante léo voulait commencer
sur la question de la privatisation je
ne suis pas sûr que ce soit une solution
pour résoudre la le manque de
représentativité de notre nos médias
juste patient fait qu'une seule solution
tu dis mais c'est comme pour pour la
démocratie on ne peut pas agiter
certaine mesure qu'on pourrait qualifier
de populiste juste en pensant que ça
résoudra le problème de la crise de la
démocratie comme le manque de
représentativité dans les médias sont
des solutions extrêmement complexe qui
amène forcément à des solutions
complexes qui ne sont peut-être pas très
attrayante pour le grand public donc je
pense qu'en tout cas sur cette question
après la citation il soit tu vois c'est
une bonne chose pour pour la démocratie
pour la pluralité des médias et sur la
question des libertés par rapport aux
passes annie terre dans les émissions
politiques d'accès dans la passe place
axiale voilà justement je ne suis pas
est un jeu passionnant que ça aille à
l'encontre de la liberté d'expression
par deux interprétations forcément dupas
sanitaire et du pass vaccinale on
pourrait la maudire la première
interpellation a peut-être la plus
simpliste ce serait le diariste et un
autre à nouveau liberté mais une
deuxième interprétation qui moi me
paraît plus qu logique entre une humaine
ou à laquelle je souscris plus c'est à
dire que le pass sanitaire nous permet à
tous de d'avoir plus de liberté et
d'être et de faire ce qu'on souhaite
dans la société c'est entre guillemets
un mal pour un bien et donc je ne vois
pas en tout cas dans ces mesures un
recul de la liberté d'expression
dans notre champ politique
juste en quelques mots je rejoins
beaucoup de vidéos soir climatisation je
suis d'accord avec léo c'est la
privatisation n'est pas en elle-même une
solution elle peut être une composante
de la solution si on observe un système
public médiatique trop important ou si
par sa place dans sur le marché il gêne
ils peuvent il peut gêner le
développement de médias privés qui en
match je pense pas particulièrement à la
radio à la télévision qui n'aurait plus
suffisamment de rené poussée des aspects
techniques de relais pour diffuser leurs
propres aux émissions ça peut être un
aspect mais on peut arriver à augmenter
le pluralisme la meilleure
représentativité c'était la bonne
formule
comment dirais-je meilleure
représentativité des
de la société par d'autres mécanismes
internes à une radio ou une chaîne de
télé ça c'est je crois que c'est vrai
sachant que la privatisation restent nos
composantes fossiles encore une fois
mais après il faut veiller à ce que dans
sur le marché
qui peut produire beaucoup de pluralisme
positif il faut faire attention aussi
aux effets de concentration donc c'est
des éléments à équilibrer et sur le post
vaccinales c'est une question très
délicate qui est vraiment importante
ce qui m'étonne moi au fond c'est que
les français parce qu'il s'agisse ici
âge il s'agit là de la france les
français semblent oublier ce qu'ils ont
vécu il n'y a pas très longtemps c'est à
dire que on a toujours en france enfin
toujours faut remonter à loin pour que
personne ne vit encore sous cet ancien
régime seule personne ne vit plus qui
aurait connu cet ancien régime en france
il y a longtemps que la vaccination est
obligatoire et qu'elle ne pose pas de
problème
pas pour le coc vite peut-être mais la
vaccination obligatoire c'est quand même
très anciens et personne n'aurait pu
dire moi je ne vous pas le maxxi n'est
ni vacciner mes enfants donc c'est une
espèce de nouveaux débats je dis pas
qu'il est vain il a l'obligation elle
est liée à la volonté par un effet de
contrainte et comme souvent en matière
vaccinale par un effet de contrainte
c'est lié à la volonté de restaurer
aussi vite que possible tout nos liberté
d'aller et venir donc en gros de
maîtriser la pandémie et je trouve
difficile d'exiger d'un public le pass
vaccinale et d'émanciper de cette
obligation de libérer de cette
obligation ce qui serait candidat au
motif qu'ils sont candidats je
trouverais ça injuste au fond et on a
pas on n'a pas notre système
démocratique que ce soit la france ou
ailleurs on n'a pas tellement de place
pour un mécanisme qui donnerait aux
candidats d des libertés supplémentaires
en quelque sorte des privilèges et en
matière de libertés que la population
n'aurait pas parce que les uns seraient
des électeurs simple les autres
électeurs candidat soit paraît difficile
de justifier cette différenciation
mais excusez moi de rebondir mais les
députés à l'assemblée sont exemples
types de passes vaccinale oui vous avez
raison j'aime raison c'est c'est une
très bonne remarque ça m'amène à dire
que dans une configuration ça c'est une
très bonne remarque parce qu'elle touche
un problème de très spécifiques dans
notre situation historique présente la
crise sanitaire qui est une crise que
chacun le sait qui a surgi
dont on ne sait pas l'origine en tout
cas ceux qui gouvernent n'y sont pour
rien ni même ceux qui sont dans
l'opposition c'est quelque chose qui
nous tombe dessus d'une ampleur
considérable on le sait avec un coût
gigantesque
bref c'est une crise qui depuis deux ans
perturbent profondément et menace même
le monde de quel qu'il soit démocratique
ou pas les gouvernants improvise dans
cette situation là inévitablement on ne
savait pas ce que c'est ce que c'était
que cette ce virus on sait mieux
maintenant on ne connaît pas tout et
donc c'est une improvisation dans les
gouvernements en situation d'urgence si
on à faire un problème de terrorisme
on a une forme de connaissance
antérieurement acquise et c'est
quand on a affaire à un virus qu'on ne
connaissait pas il faut improviser et
donc on prend on prend des décisions qui
s'efforcent je suppose de permettre à
l'état d'avoir une certaine efficacité
dans la gestion de la pandémie ce qui
peut amener à remettre en cause
un certain degré de liberté à
contraindre le confinement la
vaccination obligatoire et à préserver
le système démocratique notamment le
contrôle de l'exécutif par le législatif
et donc il peut y avoir des moments où
on a le sentiment d'une contradiction
comme celles que vous avez souligné mais
qui peut aller qui peut se s'expliquer
d'une part parce que cette
exceptionnelle qu'il faut bien personne
n'est pas le modèle prêt qui colle
partout à la cohérence mais par contre
ce qu'on peut voir là c'est qu'il s'agit
d'une espèce d'exception qui permet aux
parlementaires
de contrôler le pouvoir exécutif
sans être mis en péril par cette
question de l'obligation vaccinale sans
être perturbés par l'obligation
vaccinale je dirais que il faut admettre
le principe de l' exception si elle nous
semble justifier si ça semble pas
justifiée si on dit non il faut pas on
peut soutenir cet art 7 cette thèse est
là je ne dis pas qu'elle n'est pas
soutenable mais par rapport à la
question que vous posez à très juste
titre moi je dirais bien faut être en
mesure de de dire que c'est acceptable
de ne pas être absolument cohérent avec
les mécanismes et les principes parce
que la cohérence que l'on recherche
c'est la préservation du système
démocratique c'est-à-dire la capacité
qu'ont les parlementaires déjà élu pas à
élire mais déjà élu de poursuivre leur
tâche de parlementaires ça reviendrait
si vous voulez encore un mot là-dessus
ça reviendrait à destituer des
parlementaires du pouvoir que les actes
que les électeurs leur ont donné moins
de réélection
si on dit vous vacciner obligatoirement
bien vous ne siégeait pas on dirait les
députés qui ont été élus en 2017 qui ne
veulent pas se vacciner perdent leur
pouvoir c'est d'une façon au fond de
destituer un mandat qui a été confié par
des électeurs donc tout ça n'est pas
simple c'est de la théorie c'est du
droit public on touche à des choses
extrêmement compliqué et c'est peut-être
bonne idée d'avoir une demi mesure de
tenir bon ben tant pis on va faire une
sorte d'exception pour maintenir
l'efficacité sans toucher ou sans
craindre de toucher une pièce du système
que nous améliorer à des situations plus
graves
le débat que vous venez d'avoir est en
débat qui fait rage en france
actuellement et qui on peut l'observer a
pu amener à certaines certaine violence
c'est léo qui leur rappelait tout à
l'heure on veut être une montée de la
violence inquiétante à l'échelle
mondiale la différence un terreau perdre
la défiance interpersonnelles augmente
notamment au sein des démocraties vous
n'étaient d'ailleurs que 71% des
français pensent qu'ils n'arriveront
plus à les résoudre leurs désaccords de
manière pacifique ils sont d'ailleurs
parmi les plus pessimistes sur l'avenir
de leur pays et les plus nombreux à
penser que les désaccords conduiront à
la violence cela va plus loin puisque
les français sont 26 % à se déclarer
favorable à une possession d'une arme à
feu pour se défendre ans tandis qu'en en
europe une personne sur dix affirment
que le recours à la violence le site
pour défendre ses opinions politiques
peut être justifié ces données sont
alarmantes et son industrie
quotidiennement par exemple lors des
manifestations qui se perdent
aujourd'hui régulièrement dans la
violence nous avons pu le voir de
manière flagrante dans des épisodes des
gilets jaunes que ce soit de la part des
citoyens ou de la part de représentants
de l'ordre tout cela questionne donc la
capacité de résilience des régimes
démocratiques dans un climat toujours
plus tendus quelles armes sont à la
portée de main du modèle démocratique
français pour assurer le maintien d'un
climat pacifique assurant les libertés
de chacun aujourd'hui
alors je tendrais à nuancer malgré sa
très pessimiste parce que nous avons
essayé de montrer au cours de l'étude
c'est que certes il y à une inquiétude
effarant que l'on puisse utiliser ce
terme
dans la démo sein de démocratie
française et dans les démocraties dans
le monde une montée de la violence
tu l'a très bien dit mais ce qui ressort
c'est que
dans l'immense majorité pour plus de 90%
des des sondés la démocratie est
importante y sont attachés à la
démocratie ils sont attachés aux
libertés donc il ne faut pas le tableau
n'est pas aussi noir si noir que ça
ensuite quelles sont les armes pour
pour résoudre entre guillemets ses
craintes je pense que ça passe en
premier lieu par rétablissement de la
confiance entre les gouvernants et les
gouvernés confiance qui a été rompu mon
nom là on l'a noté dans nos différentes
études sur le risque populiste en 2022
que les français n'ont plus absolument
plus confiance dans l'ordre dans leurs
députés dans leur président dans tous
les styles des juges sauf les maires qui
sont pas épargnés par set par set
par set j'ai toute crainte on pourrait
dire ça comme ça donc en premier de ça
passerait par là ça passerait donc par
par établissement cette confiance donc
peut-être par aussi dans une exemplarité
de nos députés au sein de leur exercice
du pur
c'est c'est vrai que qu'il faut regarder
dans le détail pour avoir un tableau
composite
et
ensuite à mon tour un peu dans l'autre
sens pas du tout dans le sens contraire
et pour montrer que
c'est vraiment d'un bord à l'autre je
vous dirai d'abord pessimiste un bord
optimiste en passant de données en
données qu'on arrive à avoir un peu
mieux les deux portraits la question que
je me pose moi c'est quand les personnes
nous disent parce qu'elle nous dise
massivement les oies raison leur
attachement aux libertés et même au
gouvernement représentatif c'est à dire
des personnes élues pour nous
représenter
c'est très largement ce qui en porte le
plus de soutien et en attachement
quasiment unanime aux grandes libertés
90 % 95 98 en fin de tes chiffres tout à
fait impressionnant
une interrogation mais les venir mon
esprit je me demandais si c'était
toujours dans le sens qu'on peut donner
spontanément soi même c'est à dire
l'idée que cette liberté elle est celle
des autres aussi ou bien si c'est ma
liberté la liberté pour moi que je
chéris
éventuellement en laissant moins de
place
dans cette appréciation dans ce soutien
à la liberté de l'autre ce que je dis ça
parce que on a posé une question qui
vous a peut-être interpeller
domicile et
elodie je ne sais pas mais on a posé une
question sur le s qu'il faut laisser le
droit de vote à tout le monde ou est ce
qu'il faut le réserver à ceux qui savent
languereau de quoi il parle pour aller
vite et quand même
48% des répondants nous disent qu'il
faut réserver le droit de vote aux gens
qui savent de quoi ils parlent et 52%
dans vos générations les moins de 35 ans
vit largement moins que 35 ans mais dans
vos générations 52% c'est majoritaire on
avait déjà observé cela dans le passé
cet écart la faim dans un passé récent
en 2018 et moi je me suis interrogé
là-dessus il dit au fond quand on dit il
faudrait réserver le droit de vote oui
je pense qu'il faudrait réserver le
droit de vote à ceux qui savent si je
dis ça moi je pense que je dans le
groupe de ceux qui savent
et donc j'y vois le plus souvent je
pense que c'est ça le schéma je ne
m'excuse pas j'exclus l'autre j'y vois
l'expression possiblement
d'une tendance qu'on mesure par ailleurs
celle qui a déjà été évoqué par les
hautes teneurs sur la difficulté ou la
crainte que nous avons de tout pouvoir
résoudre pacifiquement au conflit comme
si on avait le sentiment qu'il faut
faire taire les autres en quelque sorte
et je suis pas encore tout à fait sûr
que l'attachement puissant à la liberté
qu'on mesure qui doit être assez
largement quand même un vrai attachement
à la liberté ne soit pas pour partie un
attachement à sa propre liberté avec
moins de considération pour celle des
autres
oui ok ce serait aussi un peu confirmé
par exemple par les chiffres que nous
avons vue sur le port d'armes voilà on
voit que
les
sondés sont interrogés sont attachés de
ce succès mois au port d'armes donc
alors liberté mais certains semblent
animer une liberté pour soi et non pas
pour les autres donc c'est sûr c'est un
billet con
qu'on ne peut pas qu'on peut pas notre
devoir at on à ces chiffres c'est vrai
qu'on ne pourra jamais jamais résoudre
peut-être ici on y pose différemment
aucune un futur proche peut-être on
pourra voir mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
cette limite a effectivement je pense
que vous avez raison sur le fait que
cette liberté cet attachement aux
libertés c'est une liberté individuelle
plus qu'une liberté collective voilà un
patrimoine commun
merci alors pour la dernière question va
plutôt se diriger vers la crise
écologique donc vous traitez aussi de
cette question là dans votre rapport en
considérant que les démocraties sont les
plus à même de faire face et se montre
plus volontaire cependant lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique implique
souvent d'interdiction de réduire des
libertés on se souvient notamment
comment a débuté la crise des gilets
jaunes en france avec l'augmentation du
prix de l'essence il s'agit donc d'un
défi délicat vous écrivez vous-même je
cite mal conduite dogmatique autoritaire
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique contribuera à fragiliser le
régime démocratique et le soutien de la
société en particulier celui des
catégories populaires et des classes
moyennes comment ainsi préserver les
libertés de chacun tout en réduisant les
comportements peu écologique surtout
lorsqu'on voit en période électorale
certains candidats je pense notamment
aux jeunesses de la république en marche
qui ont écrit voir d'autres candidats
d'autres groupes politiques sur
l'éventualité d'un pass écologique
maintenant c'est qu'on parle peut-être
beaucoup de passes mais c'est un sujet
qui rentrait dans nos vies alors qu'il
ya deux ans on aurait
on n'y aurais jamais cru jamais pensé
donc voilà
je devrais
le défi écologique la résolution du
réchauffement climatique
les rings est très paradoxal parce que
elle est portée par des mouvements
démocratiques par des partis
démocratiques très attaché à la
démocratie mais résoudre cette crise
c'est
presque anti démocratique il faut priver
les citoyens de certaines libertés
il faut
c'est ça va complètement à l'encontre
certaines fois de ce qu'est la
démocratie non est ce qu'il y a une voie
médiane entre préservation des libertés
et 8 contre réchauffement climatique
sûrement dans tous les cas pour
l'instant elle n'a pas été je pense se
trouvait par par le dirigeant
j'ai été sensible à l'énoncé de la
question je rejoins aussi des eaux sur
ces éléments de réponse
on pourrait peut-être préciser pour les
personnes qui écoutent cet échange que
la démocratie est plus performante pour
résoudre la crise climatique ou
environnementale parce que la
préoccupation publique pour le jeu
l'enjeu environnemental
se transforme en pression sur les
politiques
et dans le système démocratique par
définition les gouvernants sont
sensibles à la pression des électeurs
dans un système autoritaire non non pas
qu'ils soient insensibles absolument on
sait que c'est pas vrai même en chine et
enfin il est certain que les régimes
démocratiques sont plus sensibles
demande collective que les régimes
autoritaires
donc cet instant ce sens bon et puis là
on a dans les régimes démocratiques un
niveau de liberté dans l'expression qui
est aussi présent dans l' expertise ou
des individus des groupes de
laboratoires des partis des syndicats
des associations des universitaires des
journalistes
ddd
des veilleurs voilà des
anciens alerte a faim il ya tout un
monde qui peut observer dénoncé lancé
des alertes en tout genre donc on est
beaucoup plus préservé je dirais du
silence de la chape de plomb qu'on
trouvera dans d'autres régimes
politiques
mais par contre est la référence aux
dirigeants de me paraît excellente par
contre sans considérations sur l'aspect
purement écologique si la méthode pour
faire de l'écologie en france c'est la
pression fiscale et l'interdiction
réglementaire je pense que on peut au
moins dire je dis pas que c'est la
mauvaise méthode flash juger par ces
résultats par ses intentions seulement
et je pense qu'on peut dire que le
risque est élevé d'obtenir sur le plan
politique
une situation
probablement et nal moi je dirai au fond
parce que ce qu'il faut faire
pour arriver à atteindre les objectifs
qui ont été fixés
et si rigoureux si rude dans des
sociétés les nôtres qui sont habitués
depuis maintenant 70 75 ans à une
progression continue de leur confort
matériel leur niveau de vie c'est un
changement retournement culturel qui de
mon point de vue n'est pas réaliste ne
se produira pas et débouchera plutôt sur
ces grands mouvements qu'on voit en ce
moment comme au canada parle beaucoup
donc on a vu aussi en australie
qu'on a vu en france avec les gilet
jaune sous d'autres formes qui
risquerait là pour le coup de donner
beaucoup beaucoup de force au mouvement
populiste dont on parlait au début dire
que là vous devenez le chef de file de
ceux qui refusent le pass consommation
il ya même des projets dans les pays
scandinaves qui sont pensés aussi en
france je dis pas par les gouvernements
et d'autres départs sont à l'esprit
d'une carte de crédit qui prend en
compte ça c'est une réalité
l'empreinte carbone de vos achats et qui
peut même bloquer vos achats à partir du
moment où vous dépassez empreinte
carbone qui vous a été alloué ça vous le
rendront l'introduit ça dans le système
dans le système par exemple français ont
commencé que l'empreinte carbone est les
fonctions le sort de son pouvoir d'achat
parce que plus on consomme plus à une
empreinte carbone mais encore plus à
l'intérieur de cela plus au nez d'un
milieu social modeste le type de
consommation qu'on va avoir une plus
carbonées que dans un milieu social plus
riche plus aisés où on peut acheter
décarboner quelques sorte parce que
c'est c'est plus cher en bref on va
avoir des situations extrêmement
compliqué à arbitrer et je ne vois pas
comment ça pourrait conduire à autre
chose qu'à une forme de deux crises
majeures je vais pas dire que j'ai la
solution parce que je ne l'est pas mais
il ya une piste avoir quand même qu'ils
aient une écologie de croissance une
écologie d'innovation ou la
décarbonation de l'économie fait la
croissance ou le fait de tout démonter
parce que ça carbone pour remonter dans
une économie qui ne carbone plus voir
qui des carbone ou qui par exemple comme
on le voit aujourd'hui ça commence à
s'esquisser est capable de faire des
plastiques qui envahissent nos océans
une matière première vous avez peut-être
vu que le new york times a fait un
article sur le sénégal qui fait
maintenant du plastique qui arrive sur
les plages comme une catastrophe en fait
maintenant une matière première est la
ramasse et la traite et la recycle et en
tire des ressources c'est quelque chose
je pense qui indique une voie
horizons pour refaire ce qui a été mal
fait
créer de la richesse de l'emploi de
l'innovation des brevets de la
satisfaction
est donc réinventer au fond un style de
vie plus en harmonie avec les
contraintes naturelles mais qui ne cède
pas sur le besoin que nous avons tous
les ans les autres de vivre mieux ou de
penser que mes enfants vivront mieux que
nous avons vécu
merci beaucoup pour cette note d'espoir
de positivité nous allons conclure ici
de l'entrevue donc j'ai ensuite
évidemment tous ceux qui nous écoutent à
lire allez voir
l'étude que vous avez fait qu'il recense
à la fois et dans le sondage extrêmement
intéressant et parfois surprenants comme
on a pu le relever certains aussi une
analyse très fine donc de ces sondages
et de d'un certain nombre de phénomènes
pas seulement en france mais aussi à
l'étranger comme vous l'avez très bien
souligné et j'invite et également ceux
qui nous écoutent évidemment à s'abonner
à ce complot pour être au courant de la
sortie de nos prochains épisodes de
l'entrevue politique je vous remercie
chaleureusement d'avoir pris ce temps
pour répondre à nos questions c'est
extrêmement intéressant merci à vous
merci à scoopeo pour cette danse la
merci beaucoup de mythes il
merci beaucoup elodie vraiment c'était
passionnant et puis je remercie les eaux
mais quand je vois plus souvent
merci darou d'un mythe merci à vous nos
métiers